t
un marché phénoménal.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Chaussures de sport,
espadrilles, sneakers,
baskets... Peu importe comment
on les appelle, elles sont
partout.
♪ ♪ ♪
Et chez ce passionné, elles
sont soigneusement rangées.
- Voilà!
- Wow!
- Bienvenue.
- Tu as combien de paires?
- Pas loin de presque
300 paires. 300 paires...
Là-dedans, il y en a un petit
peu partout.
- Il a même sacrifié une partie
de sa terrasse pour construire
sa caverne d'Ali Baba.
- J'ai fait construire ça
pour pouvoir enfin créer
une petite pièce à chaussures.
Ça a été une longue discussion
avec ma femme.
(rires)
- Et même le jour de son
mariage, il portait
des espadrilles.
DAVID BITTON, collectionneur
de chaussures de sport
- J'ai toujours fonctionné
au coup de coeur. Ça peut être,
des fois, un petit matériel
qui est différent dessus,
ça peut être la couleur, ça peut
être la forme, ça peut être
le nom... Comme je disais,
ma basket préférée, c'est
la Air Max 1. Je pense que
je dois en avoir une vingtaine.
Des fois, la semelle est
différente. Des fois,
il y a des collaborations
aussi avec des artistes.
- Meeker Guerrier est lui aussi
un maniaque d'espadrilles.
Il vient justement de s'acheter
trois nouvelles paires.
- Je sais pas pourquoi
je te dis mes secrets!
- Sa collection a un goût de
douce revanche et de nostalgie.
MEEKER GUERRIER, animateur
et coll. de chaussures de sport
- Les entreprises sont pas
folles. T'sais, les modèles
que j'ai, en général, qui sont
les plus précieuses à mes yeux,
ce sont des modèles qu'ado,
on pouvait pas se permettre-.
- Couleurs chatoyantes,
matériaux choisis, design
innovateur... Les souliers
de sport sont des pièces
de collection.
- Moi, je suis comme un junior,
mais il y a des gens qui sont
vraiment passionnés, qui en font
non seulement une passion,
mais un métier.
- Parce que c'est un marché
énorme, alimenté par une machine
multimilliardaire.
LOLITTA DANDOY, journaliste
et chroniqueuse mode
- L'industrie des sneakers,
ça représente 80 milliards
de dollars et là-dessus,
il y a six milliards qui sont
dans la revente, et on dit
que d'ici quelques années,
on va passer à 30 milliards
en revente, donc c'est clair
qu'ils sont là pour rester.
- Qu'elles se vendent en ligne,
sur des sites spécialisés,
chez les plus prestigieux
encanteurs, dans les boutiques
où le lancement de certaines
paires d'exception attirent
des foules, prêtes à faire
la file durant des heures
pour mettre la main
sur le Saint-Graal.
- On peut penser directement
à la Yeezy, la toute première
Yeezy de Kanye West, qui a été
vendue à 1,8 million de dollars.
- Avec les prix qui s'envolent,
ceux qui ont acheté la bonne
paire au bon moment ont pris
une longueur d'avance.
- Les Jordan 4 Cement,
que j'ai pu ravoir en 2016,
je les revendrai jamais,
celles-là.
- Jamais?
- Jamais.
- Même si je t'offre 100 000 $?
- Ah, bien là! Bien là!
(rires)
Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier,
Radio